as night fell on valentine's day they
gathered in small groups in various
parts of russia
the aim to show solidarity with
opposition leader alexei navalny who's
currently in jail
in playgrounds and courtyards they place
candles in the shape of a heart
and shone lights from mobile phones the
coordinated action came in response to a
call from a man called leonid volkov
now based in lithuania he's a close ally
of alexey navalny
he wants russians to copy tactics used
by pro-democracy activists in
neighboring belarus
our force is that we are
more sophisticated than them that we are
more
creative and we have to think about
other forms of protest
and he already invented something volkov
urged people to post pictures of
sunday's gatherings on social media
using the slogan love is stronger than
fear the aim was to avoid large
demonstrations
of the type that's seen thousands of
people arrested across russia
in recent weeks among them alexei
navalny's wife who's now reportedly in
germany
and his spokesperson kira yarmish they
were among the women activists being
honoured in the second city saint
petersburg
around 100 women formed a human chain
near a monument to victims of political
repression
i think it will have an impact at least
we'll show the world that we're here
that those people are not alone that we
stand in solidarity with them
navalny was arrested in january
immediately after flying back to moscow
he'd spent many months in germany
recovering after he was poisoned with a
nerve agent
an attack that nearly killed him on
friday he was in court
facing slander charges which he's
dismissed as politically motivated
he's already been sentenced to nearly
three years in jail for parole
violations
while he was convalescing abroad after
the recent crackdown his team postponed
mass rallies until at least the spring
and just a few days ago president putin
suggested the street protests were not
really about navalny
you know what this person under
investigation
is being used precisely at the moment
when in countries all over the world
including our own people are tired
irritated and discontented
about the conditions in which they live
and their income
but if the authorities continue to go
after political activists
this type of event could well gain
momentum nadine barber al jazeera